buonasera a tutti
ecco che ad essere rappresentazione in
effetti il titolo è l'isola che c'è e
vedremo anche perchè insieme perché
dovete sapere che sei anni fa proposi al
mio capo un progetto dedicato
all'educazione finanziaria le paure
femminile immediatamente lo stroncò
senza neanche rivolgersi all'interno
dell'azienda dicendomi ma tutti questi
dettagli queste informazioni
cosa vuoi la gente non gli interessa e
poi più rimangono ignoranti meglio apple
che donne per carità ci creerebbero un
sacco di problemi continua e quindi da
sola nel mio progetto e proprio perché
mi resi conto che lavorando e arrivando
per approdando qua quattro anni fa in
sicilia
imprenditrice imprenditori come durante
questo kovida hanno dimostrato una
capacità di reazione e di guidare la
riscossa
a mio avviso la sicilia potrà guidare la
riscossa di questo paese e questo perché
io credo molto nella forza del
cambiamento essendo vissuta da giovane
con due madri divisa tra quella che era
la saggezza contadina e tecnicismi
finanziari john don dice che nessun uomo
è un'isola e quindi anche la famiglia
non è un'isola e noi che siamo dentro
questa grande famiglia ecco il nostro
ruolo sociale siamo in grado di agire e
di creare di veder creata la nostra
personalità partendo da una
consapevolezza della terra del to che
diventa terra del noe verso altri io e
all'interno di questa famiglia si crea
la nostra personalità ci apriamo verso
il mondo e siamo capaci di reagire
perché questa forza di reazione
fortissima e quella che ci permette di
andare avanti di trovare un nostro
equilibrio proprio come questa
meravigliosa isola la sicilia la più
grande del mediterraneo per superficie
popolazione la prima ad essere entrata
nel regno d'italia
anche la prima ad essere un'isola a
statuto speciale isola che nel
mainstream europeo del concetto di
fluidità di sigmund baumann e per di
cambiamento e di moto dire generazioni
intergenerazionale guidato proprio dalle
donne ed è di questo che parleremo
perché da questo punto di vista
laddove si aprono spazi alle donne si
apre spazio verso tutti quanti e sono le
donne imprenditrici a essere
protagoniste di questa guida ad una
isola che c'è e da un'isola che è in
grado di coniugare realtà con benessere
ambientale che quello di cui parleremo
un benessere che è bene di tutti che
vuol dire conservazione di tutto ciò che
il capitale umano e produttivo che evita
di veder minacciata la nostra isola la
nostra comunità ma tutto questo avviene
esclusivamente laddove c'è un impeto nei
confronti della sostenibilità ma
chiariamo che questa bussola della
sostenibilità per il nostro paese è
rappresentato proprio da quell agenda
2030 che ben 189 paesi hanno firmato e
che cosa vuol dire la sostenibilità
fondamentalmente vuol dire vedere il
benessere di questa generazione che
utilizza capitale umano capitale
produttivo
diventare possibilità per le generazioni
future di poter continuare nell'ambito
di quella che una rigenerazione e uno
sviluppo sostenibile
un'agenda che vede dei gol fondamentali
primo fra tutti il gol 4 quello che
riguarda l'educazione l'educazione e
stiamo parlando di un'educazione di
qualità
un'educazione
e che deve essere assolutamente
equa e inclusiva una educazione che è
alla base del nostro discorso il primo
dei tasselli del puzzle ma che parte da
una fondamentale assunto di
responsabilità che noi tutti dobbiamo
prenderci verso la crescita economica
verso l'inclusione sociale verso
rispetto ambientale
coniugando impegno e responsabilità un
impegno che vede nel gol 4 soprattutto
un
ampliamento di quello che è un concetto
che non è solo globale non è solo
mondiale ma anche e soprattutto locale
lo vediamo ampiamente qua in sicilia dal
punto di vista poi dell'interconnessione
tra i vari obiettivi globali come
abbiamo visto 17 global goals e ben 169
target che come vedete abbracciano la
vita quotidiana di ognuno di noi e
soprattutto ci vedono interconnessi nel
nostro agire dal punto di vista dell
interconnessione tra l'educazione e la
parità di genere una parità di genere
che vede nel gol 5 che il gol seguente
una possibilità di avere un uguaglianza
di genere piena
un uguaglianza di genere che si lega a
un comportamento che deve essere
equilibrato sostenibile e mirato a una
vera lotta nei confronti delle
disuguaglianze le discriminazioni che
abbiamo visto a causa di questa pandemia
crescere notevolmente
da questo punto di vista poi dobbiamo
vedere proprio il fatto che dai dati che
ci arrivano dal world economic forum
purtroppo l'italia in termini di
partecipazione economica è scivolata al
100 quattordicesimo posto
e ciò dipende dal fatto che le donne
sappiamo che in italia solo una su due
lavora ancora di meno al sud e poi
abbiamo una pletora di contrasti parta
una differenza salariale un mancato
accesso alle stern ma non è solo questo
teniamo conto che l'italia si è
impegnata nella convenzione di pechino
nel 1995 insieme ad altre 189 paesi e
che cosa si diceva allora che
l'indipendenza economica delle donne
dovrebbe essere garantita dai governi
attraverso un impegno nei confronti di
quello che era la spesa pubblica
nell'accesso alle risorse produttive
nell'accesso al lavoro ma da allora
lettera morta e solo adesso si sta
riprendendo il filo conduttore di questi
discorsi perché nessuno deve rimanere
indietro e perché commissione europea e
parlamento europeo si sono impegnati per
questo green new deal che pure ci deve
salvare non solo tramite i fondi ma la
nostra azione prima di tutto un green
new deal che è fatto per il 37 per cento
di risorse che vengono dedicate al
cambiamento climatico e come abbiamo già
avuto modo di notare il cambiamento
climatico è uno dei grossi problemi
oltre 7 milioni sono i profughi
ambientali due terzi di questi sono
donne e bambine e se il clima diventa un
aspetto estremamente importante di
questo equilibrio nei confronti di una
ricerca della sostenibilità abbiamo già
visto l'educazione
e la parità di genere e chiaro ed
evidente che anche guardando le
classifiche del tesi che sarebbe
l'indicatore per l'economia digitale
siamo al ventiquattresimo posto su 26
paesi
un'economia digitale che vede l'italia
indietro in tutti i 13 indicatori e
particolarmente per quanto riguarda nei
confronti delle donne una differenza di
genere che le vede tagliate fuori tanto
digitale per videogiochi piuttosto che
per social ma molto poco per quanto
riguarda l'e commerce è tutto l'ambito
che riguarda lo specifico produttivo e
quindi il miglioramento di quelle che
sono le attività commerciali e quindi è
solo attraverso l'educazione dicevamo
che possiamo intervenire in un paese che
sempre nell'ambito di quelle che sono le
dati globali anche a livello di
partecipazione
delle donne e di conciliazione lavoro
famiglia purtroppo è fanalino di coda
quindi la lotta alla prevenzione
economica e alla prevenzione
educativa avviene solo tramite un grosso
impegno per un'educazione che l'unica
energia pulita del futuro
un'energia pulita che crea cambiamento
che crea consapevolezza aiuta le nuove
generazioni questo avviene appunto
tramite le donne tramite donne che
sappiamo in sicilia sono impegnate in
start up in start up che si occupano di
micro greens di superfood di parametri
ambientali
monitorati digitalmente per
l'agricoltura un enorme salto di qualità
donne dove la determinazione la
concretezza dei loro progetti
va a sfatare è quello che noi vediamo
fotografato dallo svimez il rapporto
sulle regioni italiane dove si dice nord
e sud uniti nella pandemia divisi nella
ripresa ecco noi vogliamo tracciare una
fotografia differente perché proprio
dalle donne sotto i 35 anni che si danno
e si impegnano nei confronti di
un'attività in proprio laddove difficile
accedere al mondo del lavoro laddove
molte imprese di grandi dimensioni hanno
abbandonato quest'isola ma ecco che il
ritorno permetta queste donne di dare
dei punti più 8 per cento di crescita
nei tre mesi di quest'anno rispetto alle
imprese del nord condotte sempre da
giovani donne e quindi attraverso questa
partnership tra donne tra l'unione di
voci tra la comunione d'intenti che
nasce il vero programma di un
cambiamento forte che diventa
consapevolezza che diventa rinascita che
diventa responsabilità responsabilità
nostra nei confronti delle nuove
generazioni responsabilità delle
istituzioni nei confronti della
cittadinanza ma solo attraverso una vera
istanza di cambiamento e di anche di
mentalità da parte di tutti quanti ed è
per questo che
incontrando donne sul territorio m'è
capitato di incontrarne alcune che sono
dedite alla viticultura ricordiamo che
la sicilia è l'unica regione in italia
dove le viti cultrici sono di più che
donne sono di più che gli uomini e
questo è avvenuto grazie a un enorme
salto di qualità che è stato fatto nella
viticoltura proprio grazie al movimento
delle donne è ugualmente in tutto quello
che sono l'ambito del riciclo delle
plastiche e dell'applicazione di questi
obiettivi globali che creano il nostro
percorso
quindi in sostanza è proprio grazie a
loro grazie al fatto che le donne sono
tessuto fondamentale di questa terra che
noi abbiamo un esempio fulgido di
cambiamento e tutti i progetti che
vengono svolti in questa terra vengono
svolti sulla base di questo impegno
comune una sicilia che e terra madre che
è soprattutto impegno comune ma che è
rivolta a la globalità perché queste
sono imprenditrici che lavorano a
livello internazionale che portano alla
cultura siciliana italiana all'esterno e
noi le supportiamo lavoriamo con loro e
vediamo nel loro sforzo quella capacità
di responsabilità che noi cittadini del
nuovo mondo di questo vecchio occidente
che si proietta verso un nuovo mondo
possono costruire veramente un futuro
mattarella l'otto marzo ha detto che il
problema dell'inclusione delle donne non
è solo un problema economico è un
problema soprattutto
culturale e sociale e quindi una vera
inclusione sociale finanziaria delle
donne sarà quella che creerà al
cambiamento ed è proprio su queste
parole su una vera coesione sociale che
quest'isola che c'è che bisogna
rispettare amare profondamente senza
ogni limite ci permette veramente di
valorizzare talenti e diversità per
costruire un futuro sostenibile come
nessuno sa fare grazie
[Applauso]